I have gastritis, and almost no stomach acid, pH of 6.
I cannot take HCL because of gastritis so far, andoscopy shows, no H. Pylori, what's
your suggestion of burberry and garlic?
I will view the video.
So go to our blog post on hypochloridria.
If you already have a lot of damage to the lighting of the stomach and even possibly an ulcer,
you won't be able to tolerate HCL.
So I have a protocol that you should start with, that you should back away from HCL and
you try apple cider vinegar prior to your meals.
Remember, you only take HCL or apple cider vinegar right before your meal.
So you're not leaving HCL in your stomach by itself in an empty stomach.
Nor are you leaving, nor are you putting apple cider vinegar in an empty stomach either.
You might put it in an empty stomach, but you're eating something right away.
Otherwise, it's going to cause irritation, especially if you have a lot of damage stomach
cells, especially if you have a damaged stomach lighting caused with an ulcer.
I wouldn't trust that you don't have HCL.
The tests that are out there for HCL are not exact.
So you really have to diagnose that based upon your symptom picture.
But if you can't tolerate the apple cider vinegar, then you have to go into just healing mode,
decalcerized licorice, glutamine, things like that that I mentioned, should be started
for a few weeks, then every week or so you try using apple cider vinegar before your meal.
Once you could tolerate that, you do that for several weeks, while you're still working
on healing that got, and then you try to switch to HCL and hopefully you'll be able to tolerate
at the time as your stomach cells heal.
So that's kind of how you walk through that blog post that kind of walk through that.